hi everyone I am May and welcome to this
fantastic video on random forest in
machine learning by simply learn if you
enjoy watching these type of videos and
find them interesting subscribe to our
YouTube channel as we bring you the best
videos daily also hit the Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
in this video we will discuss what is
random Forest after that we will see
working of a random forest and the
advantages and the disadvantages of the
random Forest after that we will see
some applications of the random forest
and at the end we will do a hands of lab
demo of how you can build a random
Forest before moving on to what the
decision tree is if you want to become
an AI expert and get handsome salary
packages look at a wide range of AIML
courses by simply run in collaboration
with top universities across the globe
by enrolling in any of these
certification program you will gain
expertise in skills like generative AI
prompt engineering chat gbt explan
enable AI machine learning algorithm
supervised and unsupervised learning
model training and optimization and
there is much more on the list with
handson experience in tools like charity
Dal python open CV and tensorflow you
will catch the eye of top recruiters so
what are you waiting for hurry up and
enroll now a year of experience is
preferred to enroll in these courses
find the course Link in the description
box below so with that mind let's get
started so what is a random Forest
random Forest is a popular tool in
machine learning created by Leo Brean
and edle Cutler it's like a team of
decision tree working together to give
one final answer people like it because
it's easy to use and can handle
different types of problem like sorting
things into groups or predicting values
moving forward let's see working of
random Forest algorithm so Step One is
Select random samples from a given data
or training set the second one is this
algorithm will construct a decision tree
for every training data set the third
one is voting will take place by
averaging the decision phrase step four
finally select the most voted prediction
result as the final prediction result so
this combination of multiple model is
called emble emble uses two methods the
first one is badging creating a
different training subset from sample
training data with replacement is called
badging the final output is based on
majority voting the second one is
boosting combining weak Learners into
strong Learners by creating sequential
model such that the final model has the
highest accuracy is called boosting
example is adab Boost and XG boost so
moving forward let's see advantages and
disadvantages of random Forest so first
we will see some advantages of random
Forest are first one is can perform both
regression and classification task the
second one is produces good prediction
that can be understood easily the third
one is can handle large data set
efficiently fourth one is provides a
higher level of accuracy in predicting
out out comes over the decision
algorithm some disadvantages are while
using a random Forest algorithm more
resources are required for computation
the second one is it consumes more time
compared to the decision tree algorithm
the third one is less intuitive when we
have a extensive collection of decision
trees the fourth one is extremely
complex and requires more computational
resources so moving forward let's see
some application of random Forest some
of the application of random Forest are
Bank
it predicts a loan applicant solvency
this help Landing institution make a
good decision on whether to give the
customer a loone or not they are also
being used to detect fraud St the second
one is Healthcare health professionals
use random Forest system to diagnos
Patient patients are diagnosed by
assessing their previous medical history
past medical records and review to
establish the proper dosage of the
patient the third one is stock market
Financial analysts use it to identify
potential markets for stocks it also
enables them to remember the behavior of
stocks the fourth one is e-commerce
through this system e-commerce vendors
can predict the preferences of customer
based on past consumption Behavior so
moving forward let's Implement random
Forest classifier using python so yes
this is my Jupiter notebook screen so
let me uh give you again a brief uh idea
about the random foret classifier So
Random Forest is a supervised machine
learning algorithm which is based on
Ensemble learning so in this ker so I
will build two random Forest classifier
models to predict the safety of the car
okay one with a 10 decision frees and
another with the 100 decision trees so
the expected accuracy increases with the
number of decision Tre in the model I
will demonstrate the feature selection
process also using the same random
forest model to find only the important
features right so we will rebuild the
model using these features and see its
effect on accuracy okay so let's start
with some some importing major libraries
okay so I first I will rename it to
random
Forest right so I will
import number as
NP for the linear
algebra and second
import pandas as PD for the data
processing right for CSV file that is
bd. read CSV we used to read and then
import met plot
Li lib do
pyplot s
PLT this m plot Li is for the data
visualization and then import
cbor as SNS so this is for some statical
data visualization and I will write here
EMP
% M plot
live
line right so I will
import
OS
for uh directory
name file
name in OS Dot
B
okay I think we don't have we don't need
this part right so let's move
forward so here I
will write import
warnings right
warnings do filter warning
ignore right the random
warnings right so here I will import the
data set so here I will write data
equals
to
car evaluation you can find this data
set on the description box
below and here I will read DF equals to
DF is nothing like data frame pd. read _
CSV then data my header equals To
None
right let me run it okay so let's uh now
we will explore some data to gain
insights about what's in data so we will
do a Eda explored data analysis so here
I will write uh I will do some random
functions use some random function like
BF do shape it will tell the how many
rows and columns present in the
data right if you want to see the data
you can write DF so this is our data
okay 1728 and S columns as you can
see right small this is this
and if you want to see the top five rows
of the data set you can use the DF doad
head is used for the top five and the if
you use tail instead of head you can see
the last five rows of your data set
right so here I will rename columns
okay because here it is return 0 1 2 3 4
56 so I will rename the column names so
column
names equals
to first one is
buying second one is for the
maintenance write
main third for
doors
persons then one is but
boot luggage
boot right and Save
T then class of the
Von okay then DF dot
columns equals
to column
names then column
names okay so these are the column names
now so if you want to see again the
column names are changed or not let's
check
see buying maintenance doors person
luxury booth and safety
class okay so if you want to see the
summary of the data set so here we can
write simply DF
doino so this is now see not null not
null object object data types you can
see right memory usage all that
okay let me give some lines yeah
so let's check the frequency
distribution of the values and variables
okay so I will check here the frequency
counts of the categorical uh variables
so here I will write column names equals
to fine okay I can copy from here
itself
yes copied so I will write for column
and column
names
print
DF
column dot value
counts
right so this is
some uh High mid low
okay this is some data types it's value
count
right so we can see that the doors and
the person are cical in nature so we can
treat them as a cical value variables
right see person and the doors they are
in cical in nature right so so there are
seven variables in the data set all the
variables are of cical data type types
so these are given by buying like this
this this main doors person luxury boot
okay and the class is the target
variable right so we will explore class
variable so here I will write DF
class dot
value
count
okay okay so the class Target variable
is ordinal in nature right so let's
check some missing values so DF do
isnull do
sum okay so we can see there is no
missing value in the data set so okay we
so I have checked the frequency
distribution of values previously
already so it also confirms that there
are no missing value on the data set
right so here we will declare feature
vector and the target variable so here I
will write X = to DF dot
drop
class comma XS = to
okay and Y = to
DF class
right so here we will split data into
separate training and the testing data
set so I will write from
skar dot do
model
selection
import
train test
split right so I will write here xcore
train comma X
underscore test comma
ycore
train comma
Yore test equals
to
train test
split X comma y
comma test
size = to
0.33 comma
random state will give
42 so it's nothing like we are splitting
testing and uh this training data set
into 0.33 0.33 means
approx uh like 66% into training data
set and the 33% into testing data set
you can say right I will run it okay in
complete
input
yeah okay X is not defined it's Capital
because it is
capital right okay too many values to
unpack expected
three okay so here I can
see as you can see it's now working it's
just a you know typ of mistake so yes
it's working
now so moving forward let's see the
shape of the X and the X Tex so you will
get to know the idea in how much percent
we splited so X
train do shape comma X test do shape
right so as you can see 1157 rows and
six in training and the testing is just
571 in the six columns as you can see
our the maximum value of the rows are
1728 into 7 column
right okay
so uh moving forward we will do some
feature engineering so feature
engineering is the process of
transforming raw data into useful
features that help us to understand our
model better and increase its predictive
power okay so here I will carry out some
feature engineering on different types
of variables okay so first I will give
some
space so here I will write x
train. d
types right it's object object
object and I will write
X
train do
head okay so we can see that all the
variables are ordinal categorical data
type so here what I will do I will will
import
Catey
category
encoders as
C
right okay
no
yeah so here we will encode categorical
variables into ordinal encoding so for
that I will write encoder
equals to
C
dot
ordinal
encoder columns name I will copy columns
name from
here and we will remove class because
class is our Target
variable
right oh
unfortunately I pasted
here right so here I will write X
train equals to
encoder dot
fit
transform xor
train then X test equals to encoder Dot
transform X
test
right
so let's
check xcore train dot
head
okay then xor test.
head so as you can see uh now we have
ready training and the test set for the
model building
okay so now I will import random forest
classifier model with default parameters
so I will write from SK
learn.
emble
import
random Forest
classifier right so here we will instate
the classifier so I will write random
Forest classifier equals
to random Forest
classifier then random
State equals to zero
right here we will fit the model so I
will write
RFC do
fit X train and the Y
train
right here we will predict the test
result test set result you can say y
prediction equals to
RFC
predict X
test so here I will
check the
accuracy
import
score right here I will write
print model
accuracy
score with 10 decision
trees this is entries
right I here write
zero 4 I need four decimal
points do
format
accuracy
score y
test comma y
prediction
right okay RFC do predict spelling is
wrong
predict so as you can see the accuracy
is 0.95 9457 almost 95% you can see so
here white test are the true class
labels and why prediction why predict
are the predicted class labels in the
test set so here I have built the random
forest classifier model with default
parameters of n estimators here I used
the 10 10 decision trees so to here I
have used the 10 decision trees to build
the model so now I will increase the
number of decision Tre and we will see
the effect on the accuracy
okay so
nothing I will copy this
whole and paste it here so
so here I will edit this
RFC
100 okay I will write
n
estimators equals to
right and let's change
now okay then y prediction underscore
100 it's y RFC
underscore
100 right here I will
write y prediction
uncore
100 so as you can see the model accuracy
score with 100 decision Tre is against
0.94 57 so the model accuracy score with
10 decision Tre is
0.92 it's not 0.94 57
right and the with the but the same with
the 100 decision trees as well so as
expected accuracy increases with the
number of decision frees in the model
okay sorry I forgot to write here 10
give okay so as you can see here the
model accuracy score with 10 decision
Tre is
0.924 7 here I have given n estimator is
equals to 10 and but with the same with
100 decision trees an estimator equal to
100 the accuracy is 0.945 7 so as
expected accuracies increases with the
number of decision trees with the model
right so here we will find some
important features with random forest
for that I will write
here
clf equals
to okay I will copy
this right and I will fit it
cf.
fit uh into the training set
X train comma Yore
train
right so now I will use some feature
importance variable to see feature
importance is score
okay so here I will
write
feature score
to PD
do
series clf
dot
feature
importance comma
index = to
xcore train do
columns do
sort
values and
ascending ascending equals
to
false
right so let's see the feature
score featur
scores so as you can see the feature
score is this for the particular columns
okay so we can see the most important
feature is safety and and the least
important feature is go right and the
least is
St so here let's visualize the feature
so SNS doar
plot X = to
feature scor Comm yal to
feature scores.
Index right PT
do X
label is
feature
importance
score then PLT do
viable
features and P do
title is
visualizing visualizing important
features right then PLT do
show okay fees scores it
is okay it's it's
label yeah as you can see okay is the
most important is safety and the least
importance
door right so now moving forward we will
see uh confusion metrix and the
classification report
right so now let's create confusion
Matrix so for skan do
Matrix
import
confusion
Matrix
right so here I will write confusion
Matrix equals to
confusion
Matrix in y
test comma y
prediction right so here I will write
print confusion
Matrix
okay for the next line comma
CM okay so this is confusion Matrix now
we will create some classification
report so here I will write from escalan
do Matrix
import
classification
quod
print
classification
p y test comma y prediction okay so this
is you can see this is you know
classification report so what we did in
this report project I build the random
Forest classifier to protect the safety
of the car so we use two models uh 100
decision trees and 10 decision trees for
the 10 decision trees is
0.947 but the same with 100 decision
tree is
0.945 so I have used the random forest
model to find out only the important
feature build the model using the
features and see its effect on the
accuracy right so we find the doors at
the least safety and the safety is the
highest so the second least important
model is uh you know luggage boot if I
remove it from the model and rebuild the
model then the accuracy was found to be
0.854 Z okay it is significant drop in
the accuracy so I will not drop the uh
drop it from the model okay so at the
last we will use confusion matrics and
the classification report are another
tool to visualize the model performance
okay so so they yield uh at the good
performance okay so thank you for
watching this video till here if you
have any query please ask them in the
comment section below our team of expert
will reach you as soon as possible thank
you for watching stay safe and keep
learning with simply learn staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here